las redadas nocturnas y las detenciones
masivas no frenan a los manifestantes
antigolpistas birmanos de salir a las
calles de mianmar en rechazo a la junta
militar que continúa reprimiendo las
protestas de forma violenta empleando
incluso munición real durante la noche
del sábado en rangún el ejército detuvo
entre otros funcionarios o miembro local
del partido de la líder de puesta en
sant sus y su familia anunció la muerte
del joven en custodia uno de los líderes
civiles del barrio de rangún que fue
arrestado anoche fue declarado muerto
esta mañana por la junta kingman la
también presidente del distrito 7 de la
nl de fue capturado por la fuerza
después de la violenta redada anoche
desde el golpe de estado militar del
pasado 1 de febrero más de 1.700
personas han sido arrestadas y hay más
de 50 muertos las escala la brutalidad
contra los manifestantes en la ciudad de
bagan cerca de un centro arqueológico
sagrado las fuerzas de seguridad
dispararon balas reales en la capital de
tailandia bangkok miles de inmigrantes
birmanos se congregaron frente a las
oficinas de naciones unidas
siguiendo acciones reales para terminar
con la violencia en su país y la
liberación de los
pérez políticos democracia eso es lo
único que pedimos es lo único que
necesitamos en este momento
la necesitamos porque mi pueblo está
muriendo la necesitamos
sin embargo la onu hace lo que hace
deben ayudarnos deben hacerlo tienen que
escuchar nuestras voces
no deberían quedarse callados de esta
manera tienen que hablar por nosotros
porque mi pueblo está muriendo nuestro
pueblo está muriendo hablen por nosotros
apoyen nos
desde rangún a mándala y el movimiento
de desobediencia civil ha convocado una
movilización masiva para el lunes pero
los medios de comunicación estatales
advirtieron que los funcionarios en
huelga serán despedidos